Pages contains all the innovation,
so what you need to do is preserve those
who are innovative,
get the hammer,
no reward for being innovative,
and the founding fathers put that in the
constitution.
It's interesting,
everybody talks about the rights of
people this,
right?
That right.
I went to a graduation,
my wife got a doctorate in public health
and the speaker said,
you have a right to good health or
saying what are they talking about?
They've lost their minds.
It means I'm never going to have a tooth
to gang.
I've never even had a stomach ache,
you know,
I ever write to,
not have cancer or something,
who going to give me these rights?
The only right that is spelled out in
the constitution is the copyright.
And what it says is those who innovate
should get the reward for their
innovation,
for copyright from patents and a general
ip on that.
And Lincoln was a big believer in this.
In fact,
Lincoln took out some patents and uh,
he loved the idea of that.
So when you think to yourself,
what could encourage innovation?
A lot of conventional thinkers who would
say,
oh,
just you know,
for the government to spend a lot more
money on our end date,
the founder says,
well,
that's fine,
but the best thing we can do to spur our
r and d is not spent any money but to
provide it so that the creators get to
keep what they have.